bene i ragazzi vedere di questo
nuovissimo video e ultimo credo ultimo
di harry stickman siamo sul finale
finale perché abbiamo già fatto complete
in the mission che è il finale di
appunto eri stigma completing the
mission ha un sacco di fina linea tipo
chiaro a noi ne abbiamo fatti adesso
vediamo il mi ricordo più abbiamo fatti
tipo 4 esatto per farli tutti i ragazzi
mi avete eletto nei commenti e l'ho
letto dai commenti perché quando uscire
dai commenti di leggo che effettivamente
bisogna sbloccare tutti finali della
delle altre missioni io non ce l'ho
proprio tutti tutti tutti però avevo
diamo quello che mi rimane da fare ok
quindi cappello e cappello mi mancano
come finali perfetto le vediamo che
succede
vado perché non li potremo mai fare
tutti sono troppi però mammamia almeno
un altro episodio devo fare perché
sicuramente qualche altro finale lo
becco oddio dopo che aveva tradito e
dopo che vanno tradito questo bellissimo
quindi quando hanno fatto cadere dalla
scip ok quindi sono non sono morto mi
state dicendo questo mi hanno
rimpiazzato il braccio a sto ancora
cercando di recupero a una bambina mi ha
rimpiazzato metà corpo sono un cyborg
belli adesso capitol emi escono fuori
tutti i gadget va bene adesso torno se
no non ci credo ci torno sopra dopo che
mi ha tradito raga bellissimo sanford
campo e lo spirit forti
[Musica]
ci riesco
diversivo il torino
[Musica]
[Risate]
un bambino guarda mamma mia mamma mia
come quando è valsa la pena fare queste
peace quanto qualche passo la pena fare
se l'episodio che un'onesta tana giorgio
reference c'erano 20 milioni però fa
niente sono contento come una pasqua era
bera per aver stato bellissimo mi preme
parlare va già bene così facciamo blaine
forms let's go presto se è quello di
prima retico le cherry ott no chissà che
questa abnorme baseball bat e i type
bull y questa non la so ragazzino no non
ho colto la la reference prova bene
minchia ma per al solo un fenomeno c'era
solamente troppo forte sono mai morto
rete mt fine ce l'ho fatta e sta
accadendo lessi el.en ship drop all
staple drop
beh tu l'hai fatto a me io lo posso fare
attenzione a nel finale contrario
praticamente adesso tu ma dai test match
è che rende coppe e sono pure morto ma
porca vacca in paracaduti cosa che ho
fatto l'ho attaccato al muro bene è
morto lui è morto
michel comte riflesso brothers
fantastico
e stato proprio figo war is happening
siamo riusciti da complesso un giorno
dal lancio che adesso abbiamo preso
sociale e stiamo andando alla base di
don paolo valenti abbiamo un vagone
pieno di solito in tempo presso grandi
ed averlo camuffato con l'alcol
una moneta gigante ottima idea ottima
verrà veramente ottima idea
poi abbiamo anche la radio nel carro
armato si porca vacca
[Musica]
se siete decidere ebbene sì con le spade
a buy
grazie ho schiacciato al volo e tutto
quindi ho fatto giusto nello sbagliare
va bene c'è un tizio diamo un grassone
soldi o meno le fiere e usiamo il fulton
di metal gear chi sistema punta non si è
questa cosa qua metti un paracadute che
aspiri c'è che scorre per essi sono
fatti interni bomb com
cosa sta succedendo lega mi sembra un po
eccessivo effettivamente però abbiamo
fatto vedere le elezioni che non ho
messo questo è morto subito
nell'altro ci abbiamo messo due ore a
farlo fuori qua abbiamo picchiato i due
ce l'abbiamo fatta
tutto giusto raga non l'ho sbagliato
niente non sbaglia niente stop in area
potuto giù tutto corretto bellissimo che
culo allora mi sono alleato col governo
ok e sono fuggito gonelli dal complesso
vediamo cosa succede in partenza due ore
prima del lancio
ok ma noi quando c'eravamo schianta si
collega facevamo schiantati qua loro
capitano l'avevo visto che la la cima
del razzo capirla cosa facciamo questa
cosa
va bene non chiedetemi perché non è
andata esattamente come speravamo ma fa
niente non c'è una giusta no che siamo a
posto
praticamente si sviluppa tra ma in
quattro punti diversi oggi che arrivano
allo spazio che sono già alla fine o che
sono qua che siamo a tre quarti o nel
treno che è due quarti o in partenza con
l'haircut un quarto facciamo bild tipo
minecraft ecco che cosa sto vedendo cosa
ma cosa vedo e bellissimo sto male
eccovi ti blocchi ho trovato le scarpe e
lo stick perché sono uno stigma e
geniale sto gioco
berra secondo me no fia questo e donkey
kong immagino va bene non è male calore
un historia de ski sexy ed hot five chi
mente nomi davvero che culo perché
mercato a caso l'udc ha cucinato acqua
siano sul ponte quello che avevano
spaccato l'ha travolta salve fusione
scovare michea dragon ball dai capelli
rossi
norme che buttiamo giù che parla anche
l'occhio con le funzioni imbrago molto
chiuso madonna
[Musica]
madonna ragazzina reference taliani
visto il territorio è veramente powerful
ci hanno fatto delle reference di anime
pazzeschi normalmente questa roba va
avanti per tre ore lo so ho visto dragon
ball diversivo terna format sarà fatto
torna per bot ma va bene è fabio rovatti
qua bellissimo l'intermezzo che fa foti
è bellissimo bravi ragazzi erano tutti
fattacci grasso voi dentro
o siamo partiti male che quello che
facciamo ora risplende ellis band
charles plan
ma c'è grande splendid rai eri il mio
piano è cosa cosa cosa sono curioso di
vedere quale l'harris plan
siamo andati al city schianta mission
complete per il nice
è certo
infatti se vi sembra un po eccessiva
influire sannino macchine a ok
dobbiamo farla malandata completa lo
sapevo lo sapevo
tutti arrestati al complesso però qua è
stato il più bello episodio di harry
stickman da quando gioco è di stigma e
non ci sono cazzi e bellissimo vero vi
sia piaciuto anche a voi a me io la
parte di giorgio veramente non era fatta
benissimo poi la parlata giapponese
fantastica per avere se rifiuta
qualsiasi momento e mi piace anche ai
social che collina dove la schizzare se
non si chiederà come sempre ci vediamo
allora prossimo video
[Musica]